one of the Senators in your state is a
very prominent senator harry reid and
you've had some run-ins with him in the
past he's lately been outspoken against
the brothels in nevada what are your
impressions of Harry Reid and his latest
crusade against Brock well Uncle Harry
we love Uncle Harry you know we
supported him for a long time we donated
money to his campaign Harry's an old
Nevada he grew up in the brothels in
searchlight Nevada there was 14 of them
there he swam in the swimming pools he
ate off the money that his mother earned
off the working girls in Nevada she was
a laundry lady so he gets it he knows
what it's supposed to be like and he
knows that rural Nevada it's the right
thing to do now for whatever reason he
decided to take the shot and and who
knows where that came from was the
gaming cartel probably probably because
they support him and so he stood up at
the legislature and said it's time for
Nevada to grow up it's time for us to to
get rid of legal prostitution and then
he stopped for applause to freshman
senators clapped twice and then they all
looked around at each other and that was
the end of it yeah I did a press
conference I want to CNN and what what I
said that resonated across America was
Harry Reid is going to have to take the
keys to the cathouse out of my cold dead
hands
you